Solo: A Star Wars Story isn't set to fly into
cinemas until May 25th, but a handful of lucky
movie lovers got to board the Millennium Falcon
ahead of time for a journey to a galaxy far,
far away.
The latest entry in the sprawling Star Wars
franchise, Solo had its world premiere May
10th in Los Angeles, and those who attended
the star-studded event have taken to social
media to spill their spoiler-free thoughts
on the Ron Howard-directed standalone.
IndieWire film editor Kate Erbland writes
...
"It takes a bit for it to find its feet and
for Alden Ehrenreich to turn on enough charm
to make you forget he’s not [Harrison Ford].
But once it kicks into its hey-let’s-make-a-crew
and yes-also-do-a-heist stuff, it totally
flies."
Erland also gushed about Donald Glover's "delightful"
performance as young Lando Calrissian and
praised Phoebe Waller-Bridge, who voices Lando's
droid companion, L3-37
Yahoo Entertainment senior correspondent Kevin
Polowy felt much the same, writing that while
Ehrenreich's performance is excellent, L3
is the real scene-stealer.
Polowy also noted how the film's overall tone,
which is lighter in comparison to its mostly
serious predecessors, works to its advantage.
"Solo: A Star Wars Story is reaaaaalllly good.
Fun as hell.
It's a straight intergalactic heist movie,
kind of refreshing to see a Star Wars movie
without a Death Star or the rebellion's fate
at stake.
Alden Ehrenreich is super impressive as Han,
but L3 might be my favorite new character."
Angie J. Han of Mashable echoed those sentiments
while also giving a sweet shoutout to Thandie
Newton's Val:
"Alden Ehrenreich is the real deal, Thandie
Newton is who I want to be when I grow up,
and Phoebe Waller-Bridge's L3… well we'll
talk about that later."
Mike Ryan, senior entertainment writer at
Uproxx, called out the first half of the film
as "hit and miss clunky," but says once the
heist plot is in full swing, it's "a whole
lot of fun."
Ryan also calls Donald Glover's Lando "legit
fantastic" and, in perhaps the most intriguing
reveal about the film so far, says ...
"It's not really hiding the fact it's setting
up more Han Solo movies."
CinemaBlend's Eric Eisenberg was even less
enthused, sharing one of the few not-quite-negative-but-not-positive-either
reactions thus far.
"Solo: A Star Wars Story is … fine.
It's slow to find its footing, but picks up
in the second act, and it's definitely fun.
Has the occasional prequel problem answering
questions I didn't need answers to, but also
some fun references.
Overall I liked it, didn't love it."
Off that lukewarm response to Solo, there's
a flurry of wonderful words from Slashfilm
head Peter Sciretta, who praised the film
for its portrayal of young Han Solo and for
its unexpected twists:
"Solo was a blast.
[Screenwriters Jonathan and Lawrence Kasdan
nail the character of Han Solo.
Yes, the story is a series of expected events
[...] but none of them happen as expected.
Stay away from spoilers, big Marvel-level
s--- that will make you wonder where Lucasfilm
is headed next."
Sciretta concludes that the finished product
more than makes up for the production troubles
the project faced — including the firing
of original directors Phil Lord and Christopher
Miller.
"Regardless of any of the production problems,
the finished film is going to make most fans
happy."
Fans can decide for themselves how Solo: A
Star Wars Story stacks up when the film hits
theaters on May 25th.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!